I posted a video of me garage selling
this Saturday there were people who
thought I staged it like do you really
think I with everything I've got going
on in my life and the leverage and all
the good stuff that my new plan my new
plan was you know what this Saturday I'm
gonna trick people
I'm gonna go to some store and buy
things and make like what is a matter
with people then somebody else is like
what is this all leading to a ten
thousand dollar how to make money on
ebay course I'm like yet [ __ ] a ten
thousand dollar to make money on ebay
course no [ __ ] it's for me to spend
some time with my kids
and the show people that this is the
world I came from as a kid it's still
tangible there's a shitload of you that
could actually really benefit from three
hundred dollars a week more and money
learn something including the thrill of
the hunt and how to how to educate
yourself to know the value of things how
did you copy and salesmanship in eBay
environment which is the most ultimate
competitive environment and how to
hustle because while all of you were
sleeping Saturday morning I was out
going from [ __ ] trash that's what